eh ben ça que vous suivez l'audience de
ce jour comment se déroulent les
échanges les gouttes et sophie c'est une
deuxième journée d'audience pour ce
procès hors normes de julian assange
inculpé par la justice américaine et
d'espionnage hier les avocats américains
james lewis lui reproche la publication
en 2010 de documents top secret d'avoir
mis en danger des sources et des témoins
18 chefs d'accusation
hier à la barre monsieur lewis l'avocat
qui représente les états unis a dit
qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'un procès que
la culpabilité de julian assange sera
déterminé aux états unis il a ajouté que
ce n'est pas au tribunal de déterminer
si julian assange et à hacker un lanceur
de l'air ou un journaliste cela sera
déterminé aux états unis après
extradition il a écarté également l'idée
que l'extradition pourrait être empêché
par l'article 10 de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme la
deuxième journée qui vient de débuter
aujourd'hui donc il y à quelques heures
c'est au tour des avocats de julian
assange se prendre la défense de leur
client
mais quelques minutes avant le début de
cette audience le rédacteur en chef de
wikileaks ainsi que le père de julian
assange ont été interdits d'audience je
vous propose d'écouter le rédacteur en
chef de wikileaks ont les quelques
minutes seulement avant le début des
audiences
j'ai été appelé par les autorités devant
la galerie du public où se trouvent les
responsables de wikileaks et l'on m'a
indiqué que le tribunal avait décidé de
nous interdire à tous la galerie du
public
on ne m'a donné aucune raison pour cette
décision est tout simplement les
responsables de wikileaks ont été bannis
de la galerie du public pour cette
audience
j'attends toujours un motif et je suis
absolument indigné par cette décision
mais cela ne me surprend pas cela
n'améliore pas ma foi en la justice de
ce pays où les gens sont mises à l'écart
notamment pour l'audience la plus
importante concernant l'avenir de
wikileaks le sort de julian assange
ainsi que celui de journaliste alors
c'est l'incompréhension dans le cas
assange après ce refus du tribunal
londonien de donner accès au rédacteur
en chef de wikileaks ainsi qu'au père de
julian assange
les avocats d'assange eux ont commencé à
plaider il parle d'un procès en vertu de
l'espionage act serait une violation des
libertés de julian assange ainsi que des
démocrates ils ont même dit que répondre
à cette demande d'extradition des états
unis reviendraient à une régression pour
la démocratie
je vous rappelle que si l'extradition a
lieu par est validée par dont on parle
très bien anglais il risque jusqu'à 175
années de prison aux états unis
2e journée d'audience comme je vous le
dis alors qu'il les soutient dans une
halle assange continue ils sont confinés
de l'autre côté de la barrière sur le
parking du tribunal des soutiens qui ont
commencé hier beaucoup de gilet jaune
français des soutiens pour julian
assange qui déclare qu' il ya fait que
son travail et ses soutiens sont là pour
sauver la démocratie comme il le disait
la liberté d'expression merci beaucoup
aux bassins chebbi depuis londres